Розрахований на 10 тисяч автомобілів на добу.
Проте останніми роками вимушений тримати на собі
до 100 тисяч щоденного потоку.
Міст Патона в Києві нині у так званому 5-му технічному стані.
Інакше кажучи, його конструкції можуть обвалитися.
Міст Патона. Відбувається прогресія руйнувань
крайніх частин даного мосту
консольної частини, і він потребує негайного ремонту.
Наразі тут заборонено рух вантажівок,
відкриті лише центральні смуги для легкових машин.
"Київавтодор" хоче зменшити на 20 тисяч тонн вагу мосту
за  рахунок заміни бетонних плит по боках,
масивних ліхтарів та парканів - вже звичайно без радянських зірок -
на сучасніші й легші конструкції з оцинкованого металу.
Тим часом, ведуться проектні роботи.
Капітальний ремонт мосту може розпочатися вже наступного року.
Негайного ремонту потребує і міст Метро.
Як мінімум, треба укріплювати арочні конструкції.
Вартість капремонту мосту оцінена у приблизно 60 мільйонів євро.
"Київавтодор" розраховує провести його на кошти ЄБРР,
оголосивши міжнародний тендер.
Загалом в столиці України, за інформацією підприємства,
в аварійному стані перебувають 27 мостів та шляхопроводів.
Вони усі потребують негайного капремонту.
Але одночасні роботи на всіх об’єктах неможливі.
Стільки коштів з бюджету столиці поки не виділено, і бюджет на цей рік
має бути використаний не лише на ремонт мостів, а й доріг,
які також перебувають не у найкращому стані.
Кожного року орієнтовано, щоб виконувати роботи
на 4-5 спорудах саме капітальний ремонт,
реконструкцію, необхідно близько 3-4 мільярдів гривень
В цілому на капітальний ремонт,
реконструкцію і будівництво в поточному році
виділено на всі об’єкти, їх близько 15-ти,
1,5 мільярда гривень.
Ситуація, коли автодорожні підприємства розриваються між зруйнованими дорогами
та мостами, які обвалюються, майже в кожному регіоні.
За словами експерта в галузі транспортної інфраструктури Олександра Кави,
найгірший стан справ з мостами у Західній Україні, де споруди руйнують повені.
В цілому по Україні в аварійному стані перебувають до 20% мостів.
І причина критичного стану споруд,
які будувалися здебільшого 40-60 років у тому,
що ані державна, ані місцева влада, ані відомства, які відповідають за мости,
упродовж багатьох років не виділяли кошти на їхнє якісне обслуговування та ремонт.
Багато чиновників просто регулярно посилалися на нестачу коштів
і доводили деякі мостові споруди до критичного стану експлуатації.
І після цього починалися ремонти.
Ми бачимо ситуацію з Шулявським мостом або шляхопроводом в Києві...
Так званий Новий міст в Дніпрі, за висновками мерії, теж міг обвалитися
через пошкоджені вертикальні та горизонтальні балки.
Капітальний ремонт мосту, відповідно до проекту,
оцінили в півмільярда гривень і планували зробити упродовж року.
Капремонт пришвидшило політичне парі між президентом Зеленським
і мером Дніпра Філатовим:
відремонтувати міст не за рік, а за два місяці - до 14 вересня 2019-го.
Можливо, президент і зламав плани мера
відкрити міст напередодні місцевих виборів,
проте пришвидшені роботи навряд чи вплинули позитивно на якість ремонту,
переконаний дніпровський активіст Денис Селін.
По  факту, вони замінили на ось цьому мості
три великі балки
і декілька балок - 9 або 12 - вони відремонтували.
А коли ми кажемо про вертикальні опори, їх ніхто не торкався.
Фактично капремонту не було
Бо щоб був капремонт, треба міняти усі аварійні балки.
Втім, мер Дніпра Борис Філатов в інтерв’ю DW запевнив,
що пришвидшення ремонту не позначилося на його якості.
Тепер він не розвалиться. Як мінімум, 20 років гарантія.
От ми сперечалися. Я знов не хочу повертатися
до того, хто переміг, а хто ні.
Це єдиний міст, який в Україні повністю відремонтований
за кошти місцевого бюджету.
Він коштував громаді 500 мільйонів гривень
І нам від держави не дали ані копійки.
Місцеве самоврядування внаслідок реформи децентралізації має набагато більше коштів
для вирішення своїх інфраструктурних проблем.
Як каже експерт з транспортної інфраструктури Олександр Кава,
територіальні громади можуть спрямовувати на ремонт доріг та мостів,
як мінімум 20, а то і 35 % відсотків коштів дорожнього фонду.
Допомоги держави можуть потребувати швидше не великі,
а маленькі міста, які мають на балансі великі мости.
Бюджет Києва - 63 мільярди гривень.
Якби міська влада інвестувала ці кошти і не займалася б корупцією,
то всі мости знаходилися б в ідеальному стані.
Бюджет Дніпра - більше 20 мільярдів гривень.
В принципі, раз на 30 років виділити
500 мільйонів гривень на ремонт моста -
для Дніпра - це абсолютно посильна сума.
В Запоріжжі, в принципі, такі об’єкти абсолютно
посильні для міського бюджету.
Просто треба  правильно розставляти пріоритети.
Правильні пріоритети - це в першу чергу якісний бюджетний менеджмент
і об’єктивна оцінка технологій, їхньої ефективності та вартості.
Як вважає дніпровський активіст Денис Селін, це те, що бракує владі на місцях.
Такий висновок він робить на підставі аналізу вартості ремонту Нового мосту в Дніпрі.
За пів мільярда гривен точно можна було реконструювати основну кількість балок.
Тобто для того, щоб це зробити - основні опори,
треба було використовувати сучасні технології.
За ці кошти можна було реконструювати повністю,
або так, як вони зробили, можна було зробити за кошти вдвічі менші.
Мерія Дніпра заперечує, мовляв, вартість робіт адекватна проблемі.
Проте питання до якості та вартості робіт з ремонту мостів
до влади мають не лише активісти Дніпра, а і Києва, і Запоріжжя тощо.
Опитані DW громадські організації вказують і на недостатню реакцію
з боку правоохоронних органів на різні порушення.
Втім, в будь-якому випадку, і активісти, і чиновники, і будівельники згодні,
що попри усі негаразди, кількість ремонтів аварійних мостів та шляхопроводів,
порівняно з періодом 2010-2015 роки,
за останні п’ять років збільшилася в середньому в 8 разів.
Хоч більше сотні різних мостів, як і раніше, закриті для руху.
В Офісі президента цю ситуацію обіцяють змінити завдяки програмі
"Великого будівництва" і доріг, і мостів.